why didn't Rishi sunat change his mind
about heading to cop 27.
well I think uh Richard zunak's always
been very very keen and has actually
financed a lot of funding in the past uh
on climate change but actually just come
in as prime minister obviously we've got
this huge uh hugely important uh task of
settling the economy the awesome
statement coming up I think he just
wanted to make sure he had that in hand
before jetting off with that I think
having worked on very intensively he's
now gone there and as you say he'll be
making further announcements on climate
later today so there's no more work to
be done now ahead of the 17th of
November on the economy
I think the chancellor still working
very hard on it and I know that I've
been working with with the PM the
chancellor and myself on the the
business the climate the energy aspects
of that but um but I think the you know
the vast uh amount of Works uh been done
and so he felt it was uh you know
appropriate to leave the country but as
ever and I think it's a good thing in a
prime minister his first priority is to
make sure that uh particularly with that
rather choppy period that we've been
through
um that the uh that things are
stabilized here oh you've been working
on it as well the Autumn statement
what's in it
well of course you'll have to wait until
the 17th so not not too long now um
I mean I think as yeah it's a good worth
try Okay uh he's gone hasn't he because
Boris Johnson's there that's why the
Prime Minister just decided to go
well no I don't agree uh I I look as I
said rishi's actually put a lot of uh
funding into
um climate uh throughout this time as
Chancellor before he became a prime
minister he's out there today uh
announcing uh 65 million pounds uh for a
green NG uh projects in developing
countries and actually I'm here in in
teesside today
announcing a a very important a lithium
Refinery green lithium Refinery the
first in not just this country but the
first in Europe this is all about being
much more energy uh independent NG's
sovereignty for the UK this will reduce
about seven percent of Europe's entire
lithium refined lithium needs in years
to come don't need to worry about
lithium batteries I mean they're not
particularly stable batteries are they
um well I mean lithium's involved in all
sorts of batteries from products we use
in homes on mobile phones to Motor Cars
we we drive I've driven an electric car
for the last three or four years seems
perfectly stable uh to me and actually
I've always thought with
um you know things like electric cars
people think nothing of driving around
with petrol cars with essentially
explosions going on in the engine uh you
know in order to create the create the
uh the the the momentum for the car for
the motor for the engine but you know
that's that with the electric vehicles
you certainly have a lot less of of that
going on so okay no I think the safety
record's pretty good
yeah well I think Airlines might
disagree with you many of them do want
to carry them
um that's your physics lesson this
morning kids you can head off to school
now talk to me about fossil uh fuels
though um profits on fossil fuels should
those
um be uh subject to a windfall tax is
that something that perhaps the Prime
Minister should be talking about while
he's over at cop 27.
I think that might be a clever way of
asking me what's in the awesome
statement again uh but you know we we
will be setting that out and the
chancellor will be setting that out very
shortly I mean it is the case that
because fuel prices have been so high uh
there have been unexpected uh profits of
course but I think it's important that
we do carry on investing in making sure
not on fossil fuels but on the renewable
energy as well that we've we've got the
capacity we've got the uh the ability to
to get that market moving which is why
the lithium Refinery that I'm talking
about here in the Northeast today is so
important but you will need to wait as I
say till the 17th till the uh to the
awesome statement I think I think you
gave us which measures are in there sure
I think it was a massive hint there so
I'm just going to leave it at that um
but what I do want to ask you about is
international trade I'm looking at the
front page of the times this morning and
basically half of the not International
Trade the International Development were
supporting those that can't support
themselves was 0.7 percent of GDP down
to point five percent were told because
we got a 4.7 at the moment and according
to the front page of the times this
morning half of that almost half of that
is being spent here in the UK so that's
you know that's just clever accounting
isn't it
well I mean they're very strict rules
actually for what uh can qualify uh as
um Aid uh and those those are set down
in a way that that ministers can't just
change uh it's always been the case that
uh people who come to the UK under
certain circumstances Asylum Seekers for
example uh are a part of that
expenditure of course what we've seen is
that large number of people uh traveling
across the English Channel uh with
people traffickers
um and uh and those numbers have been
high and so some of that money is used
in in that way but there's nothing new
that that's always been the case you
were homosexual I think well for five
days
um in total but while you were there you
had a look at the paperwork and you said
got to get some of these Asylum Seekers
out of uh these units were we've seen
what's happened while I've been away and
and the problems that were caused there
why were you so desperate to get them
into hotels
well simply the um we've got to be
careful not to break the law ourselves
by detaining um people who are able to
be outside of that what is not a
detention center but a processing center
at manston so really just a question of
making sure that we were acting within
the law and and that's something that
the Home Secretary is is continuing to
do now
um so you know really just a question of
making sure that uh we're first of all
trying to do all we can to prevent
people from making that perilous
dangerous Journey being people
trafficked and then secondly making sure
that we keep ourselves within the law uh
not detaining people when in fact they
are able to be moved on rather than kept
in what's just a processing center so we
were breaking the law
well the advice I have was very clear
that we were in danger of doing that if
we weren't acting uh and I did act uh
during six days uh in the job and I
noticed that the Home Secretary has
continued to uh act now as well yeah but
the previous Home Secretary that is now
the present Home Secretary I'm sure we
can keep up on that one
um she was breaking the law was she
well I didn't see the advice that she
was um getting what I saw was uh that
the numbers had increased when I got
there uh the advice was very clear
um it was that we needed to do a number
of different things not just actually
moving people out there's a a way of
reconfiguring the processing center in
order to make sure that we were
maintaining uh uh the the kind of
correct legal structure for what is as I
say a processing center not a Detention
Center uh and I took that decision as
well and the Home Secretary has
continued on the same path so I think
we're at one about it because you need
to be done yeah I didn't see the advice
beforehand but I saw what I was did you
ask for it did you ask to see the
previous advice uh
no so I mean normally what happens is
you as as a secretary of state you're
provided with advice and you're invited
to take it into account to make the the
Judgment based of it the advice was very
clear to me I didn't see the advice from
a from prior to me that would be unusual
it's not uh information that came to me
um but I do know that the Home Secretary
has continued along the same path that I
set during that week that I was in the
office which was of course before Rishi
sunak became prime minister okay because
as you know the suggestion is that Zola
bravaman the previous Home Secretary the
president hope secretary
um ignored legal advice I mean that
would have been wholly inappropriate
wouldn't it if that was the case
it was hard for me I said I didn't see
that advice it's hard for me to comment
on what I do know is the advice is very
clear to me I acted immediately on that
advice uh it may well be that numbers
have been changing very quickly during
that period with new arrivals uh and I
know that she has continued along the
same path so as I say I think we're
moving in the same direction there okay
do you support nurses going on strike
for better pay
well look I think first the first thing
to say is we all remember what an
extraordinary job they were doing my own
dad is I'm sure you will recall because
we spoke at the time was in hospital
through uh covert they were doing a a
great job uh I know that a million NHS
workers got 1 400 pounds rise last a
year on top of uh I think a three
percent uh Rise
um I very much hope that the NHS uh
nurses and others can can get this
resolved because uh clearly
um it'd be damaging to everybody if
nurses went on strike we all care about
our NHS we all care about our health
service so so no one would want to see
that happen I think probably including
the nurses so we care about them enough
to give them more money
well there's a there's an independent um
pay body that makes the recommendations
I I believe we accepted it uh last year
um I'm not in a position to sort of
preempt either what they decide or what
the the pay body does but as I say I
know a million workers got 1400 pounds
extra uh last year and you know everyone
it's in all our interests to see the NHS
working we all care passionately about
it we rely on it and uh you know strikes
uh won't help anyone I hope that is
resolved
how do you feel about Gavin Williamson's
messages to the then Chief whip
uh well I don't think there were uh it
was the right thing to do to send
messages like that I I see they must
have been sent in a moment of of uh
frustration
um but you know I think generally it is
the case that it's much better to um you
know write things which you would not uh
live to regret later uh and uh and
especially with with colleagues and
writing things which are polite even if
you have a point of view to express I
think is not unreasonable so I I don't
think he was right to send them the
Prime Minister said the the same
um and uh I know that the uh that the
party is going for a process looking at
them at the moment how I mean
how do you feel about working with
somebody who feels it's appropriate to
talk to women like that
well look as I say it's not messages
that I want to to see sense and I would
not send them um they were sent
presumably in a moment of of frustration
um and under very different uh
period or atmosphere in Parliament
um and you know it's I always think
never sort of send messages that you're
going to regret in the in the cold light
of day as it were and it was wrong that
he sent them and there is a process now
looking at that
are you going to vote for Matt Hancock
and I'm a celebrity
I'm not no
why not
well look I just think
ing after his constituents um yeah you
know rather than uh in the jungle
somewhere uh so uh no I won't be I won't
be voting for him although I can't
promise I'll be voting for anyone at all
so uh that that might just be a mission
rather than anything else will you be
watching though I mean are you looking
forward to seeing him having to eat
crocodile anus
tempting as that is I I think I'll
probably be focusing on my job as
business secretary uh and uh and I'll be
uh off at uh cop 27 later this week as
well so I fear I might miss him
depending on how long he survives
I see what you did
um just a quick thought before I let you
go uh 60 billion pounds in cuts and tax
Rises most of it cuts
well let's wait and see I I said I know
you've definitely a third attempt to
tempt me into commenting on what will be
in the awesome statement everyone knows
it's really important that we do get
these books to balance we can't leave
this debt to Future Generations apart
from anything else it's it worries the
financial markets and that has the
tendency to push up uh rates if we're
not careful now uh what Rishi sunak and
the chance of Jeremy Hunt have done is
make sure that uh that that you know the
the concerns of the markets have been
stabilized but what we're we're working
on with this awesome statement is a
package which puts us on a a really good
path to reduce that debt in the medium
term but also support the most
vulnerable people in society so that's
what we've been working on and so you
won't have to wait long to answer all
those questions on the on the 17th of
November okay and it's definitely off
worth a pound to see Matt Hancock and
eat witchy grubs
or maybe we'll do that on replay or
something I think
joining us from T side this morning
thank you